bienvenue à tous aujourd'hui paris
s'active et se met au vert il faut dire
que le cadre s'y prête
votre territoire c'est un environnement
naturel remarquable avec ses étendues
boisées ces espaces agricoles ou encore
ses étangs et ses rivières
nous verrons comment tout a été mis en
place pour préserver cette richesse
grâce à la mise en place d'un abécédaire
de la biodiversité et la gestion des
eaux justement parlons-en chaque
chantier chaque zone d'aménagement
concerté prend en compte les risques
d'inondations ce qui permet d'être plus
réactif
on a encore pu le constater lors des
intempéries au mois de juin
surtout que ça ne s'arrête plus les
chantiers s'enchaînent la plus grande
résidence étudiante de france construit
ici c'est ronnie city ce soit 899
logements qui vont ouvrir leurs portes à
la rentrée 2007 nous avons assisté à la
pose de la première pierre des chantiers
qui permettent de donner de l'emploi à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
grâce aux plis le plan local pour
l'insertion et l'emploi
on vous en dit plus dans un instant
quant à la jada et bien c'est à la fin
de cette émission comme d'habitude vous
allez être les premiers témoins et les
premiers à en profiter vous vivez dans
un territoire où la nature est
importante mais le plateau évolué bouge
se dynamise comment aller de l'avant
tout en protégeant l'environnement
et bien c'est l'une des missions de
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
paris saclay des mesures ont été prises
pour préserver durablement la
biodiversité
voyons comment avec la marine gauthier
de le pps et wind le caire de confiance
dès 2011 l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay a mis en
place des inventaires faune flore
megan pour les habitats et les corridors
écologiques
donc les résultats de ces inventaires
font partie prenante du projet
d'aménagement du territoire et ils ont
également étaient à la base afin de
conforter ou restaurer les corridors
écologiques présents sur le territoire
donc les trames vertes et d'être en bleu
mais également pour créer restaurer des
milieux humides et terrestres en
complément de ceux présents
sur le territoire dès la phase de
chantier
le pea paris-saclay impose entreprises
des mesures à respecter en faveur de
l'environnement ça soit par exemple pour
les périodes de travaux donc ils doivent
éviter les périodes sensibles pour la
faune et la flore la reproduction pour
l'hibernation également la mise en place
de barrières pour empêcher l'accès aux
zones humides présent sur les emprises
de chantier
il y a également d'autres mesures comme
les chantiers donc à faibles nuisances
que donc faibles nuisances sonores et
faibles nuisances lumineuses la marque
on voit derrière nous et c'est une
marque a été réalisée en 2013 elle a été
réalisée en 2013 parce que on anticipe
le calendrier de réalisation des travaux
ou un habitat existant où on avait un
certain nombre d'espèces d'amphibiens
donc grenouilles tritons qui était
présent sur le rond-point de la vauvre
devaient être détruits par les par les
travaux puisque un réaménagement routier
étaient envisagées sur ce secteur dont
clamart a été réalisé en amont en 2013
pour pouvoir accueillir les populations
d'amphibiens qui ont été déplacées en
2014 de ce secteur qui n'était pas
pérenne vers cette marque qui avait les
caractéristiques qui convenait pour les
accueillir
on est capable de savoir si les animaux
qu'on a déplacé se sont maintenus il se
trouve que c'est le cas puisqu'on a une
population de triton crêté une
population assez intéressante
on a identifié chaque individu qu'on a
déplacé puisque sur la partie ventrale
ils ont des tâches qui sont
caractéristiques de chaque individu donc
on les a retrouvés donc on sait qu'elles
se sont maintenus et que ils ont grandi
suffisamment pour être à même de ceux de
se reproduire
on a des bons résultats on suit aussi la
bonne réalisation des travaux que l'on
propose on s'arrête maintenant sur la
gestion de l'eau elle est cruciale on
l'a encore vu en juin avec les
inondations qui ont touché l'île de
france et notamment la vallée de
l'yvette avec les nombreux chantiers
cette gestion se doit d'être exemplaire
mais comment est arrivé et pour quel
résultat tout de suite les précisions
d'antoine dussouy directeur général
adjoint à la stratégie
le début du projet pratiquement depuis
qu'on est arrivé
la question de la gestion des eaux
pluviales a été toujours considéré par
l'établissement public d'aménagement de
paris saclay comme une question centrale
est stratégique
le plateau de saclay bien entendu et en
hauteur et pas inondable mais en
construisant le campus nous avons une
responsabilité importante vis-à-vis des
vallées la vallée de la bièvre la vallée
de l'yvette vers lesquels russell les
eaux du plateau saclay et donc depuis le
début du projet on a toujours considéré
que la gestion des eaux sur le plateau
devait être appris mon exemplaire et que
les projets d'aménagement à toute leur
richesse elle devait traiter cette
question de la gestion des eaux
pluviales de la gestion des crues et des
événements majeurs et apporter des
réponses innovantes
même pour les plus plus importante que
les pluies de période entre 50 ans nous
avons pris des dispositions de façon à
ce que jamais les défis qui sortent des
zones d'aménagement concerté ne soit
supérieur au débit des terrains qu'on
apprend le projet donc dans tous les cas
on s'assure qu'il n'y ait pas de
dégradation du risque existant on
travaille en fait à trois échelles
différentes on travaille à l'échelle
de chacun des projets immobiliers en
cherchant à limiter au maximum
l'imperméabilisation des sols en
cherchant à mettre en place des
dispositifs de stockage adapté sur les
toits dans les espaces verts autour on
travaille à l'échelle des quartiers lors
des inondations de juin en particulier
dans la vallée de l'yvette des
inondations importantes ont eu lieu avec
des conséquences importantes pour les
habitants de la vallée
ces bassins ses ouvrages hydrauliques et
est très loin de la saturation et à la
demande du syndicat
de l'yvette et de la vienne le cigref b
qui gère les rigoles nous avons pu
fermer totalement la vanne du bassin de
façon à ce que l'impact de la zac
dans ces moments qui étaient difficiles
soient nuls
cet événement a montré l'importance
d'avoir une gestion de l'eau coordonnée
à l'échelle du plateau ça crée de façon
à utiliser tout le potentiel de ces
ouvrages pour limiter au maximum
l'impact dès que l'impact des pluies
majeur sur sur les vallées
paris saclay tv vous en mettre
maintenant sur la des chantiers phares
de votre territoire sert ndi city c'est
bien simple c'est ici que se construit
la plus importante résidence étudiante
de france à la clé 899 logement nous
sommes à gif-sur-yvette dans la zone
d'aménagement pour certains du moulon un
projet mené par le pap s et ligne city
ile de france
ici on est sur le chantier du projet
frnb city c'est ni plus ni moins que la
plus importante opération de logement
étudiant actuellement en cours en france
dans un peu plus d'un an donc en
septembre 2017
on aura ici plus de mille étudiants qui
habiteront au coeur du quartier de
moulins dans le campus urbain paris
saclay c'est un projet qui a été
développé par lynch citi ile de france
qui a été désigné en avril 2014 par le
pea paris saclay nous ce qu'on a cherché
dès le départ dans ce projet c'est de
créer le meilleur cadre de vie possible
pour les étudiants qui habiteront ici
donc pour ça on s'est entraidés deux des
meilleures agences d'architecturé
françaises lan architecture et clément
vergély architectes surdéveloppé un
parti pris en revanche électorale qui
s'inscrit dans là dans la trame qui
avaient été définis par l'urbanisme
michel desvigne ainsi que saison menu et
au mas qui est de créer un véritable
parc paysager habiter un parent qui
vient d'implanter sans bâtiment
cylindrique qui représente sur leurs
façades les muses de l'antiquité sur
felicity on a cherché à répondre à la
diversité des modes de vie des étudiants
en proposant différentes typologies
premièrement bon le studio classique le
terrain étudiants également les
colocations sont de 2,2 et 2,3 personnes
qui sont dans des proportions assez
importante pour un programme étudiants
puisqu'on à 30% de colocation et enfin
dernière typologie innovante le t1
grappes
c'est en fait un studio qui conserve sa
kitchenette et salle de bains mais qui
partagent ce qu'on appelle un salon de
grappes c'est à dire une salle commune à
12 à 16 studios
on a voulu vraiment dans cette résidence
cueillez de la vie l'animation est que
ce soit pas la cage à lapins
étudiante
qu'on a pu malheureusement faire dans le
passé vraiment créer un campus qui
répondent à la haute ambition du campus
paris saclay on a eu un défi très claire
dès qu'on a été désigné le mois de mai
on a monté le projet développé ce projet
dans un temps record avec l'aménageur
les collectivités locales
nos architectes notre pays agissent pour
tenir ce démarrage du chantier qui a
démarré en décembre 2015 donc pour 20
mois de chantier et aujourd'hui on est
tout à fait dans les temps on sera prêt
pour la rentrée septembre 2007 et c'est
avec grand plaisir qu'on accueillera les
étudiants de centrale ici à la rentrée
ces chantiers permettent à de nombreuses
personnes en difficulté de trouver un
emploi grâce aux plis le plan local pour
l'insertion et l'emploi
c'est un dispositif associatif national
voyons comment cela se passe au niveau
d'accoupler nord-ouest 91 son président
dominique fontenay est aussi le maire le
villebon sur yvette
il dresse un constat positif de son
action
le pli de là qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire plan local pour l'insertion
et l'emploi
le pli est porté par une association qui
dans le nord-ouest du département
s'appelle à tout prix il me reste 91
le pli rassemble tous les acteurs
publics qui est ce soit l'état que ce
soit la région les départements les
communes des intercommunalités qui va le
mettre leurs forces en commun au service
des demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée
au service de toutes les personnes qui
sont très éloignées de l'emploi
nous y travaillons depuis 2011 notamment
à travers la signature de la charte des
clauses sociales qui a été d'ailleurs
renouvelé en septembre de l'année
dernière est prolongé jusqu'au 31
décembre de cette année en attendant la
signature d'une nouvelle charte
il ya un travail impressionnant qui a
été fait puisque à l'heure où nous
parlons depuis l'origine de cette charte
nous avons réussi à générer 7 185 mille
heures de travail ça représente donc
plus de 2000 personnes de 1100 personnes
très précisément qui ont pu accéder donc
un emploi grâce à ces clauses sociales
donc ce que nous souhaitons bien entendu
c'est continuer notre action dans le
cadre du nouveau paysage intercommunal
est mobilisée continuer à mobiliser nos
forces nous sommes sur un territoire
exceptionnel en territoire en devenir un
territoire où déjà les les forces
économiques en présence sont extrêmement
puissante mais un territoire en devenir
tout le monde le sait sur ce grand
plateau de saclay et nous savons qu'il
ya un grand nombre de chercheurs
d'ingénieurs de techniciens supérieurs
qui vont travailler ici de même qu'un
certain nombre d'enseignants mais il y a
aussi des emplois et beaucoup d'emplois
pour des personnes qui en sont très
éloignées et nous sommes ou charge et
bien entendu de mettre en relation ces
personnes de leur propose également un
parcours d'accompagnement renforcé de
telle façon qu'elles puissent accéder
aux emplois générés par la puissance
économique de ce territoire
il
un petit coup d'oeil sur notre agenda un
grand rendez vous à ne pas rater dans
les semaines qui viennent le paris
saclay connexion c'est la première
édition ce sera le 5 juillet 2016 dans
les locaux d'edf lab paris saclay à
palaiseau chaque année plus de 2500
entreprises secret sur votre territoire
et c'est l'occasion pour ces entreprises
de se retrouver de développer leurs
réseaux et de se tenir informé voilà
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui paris saclay
tv se termine on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro
d'ici là vous pouvez vous tenir informés
sur notre site pap.fr ou sûretés fil 78
bien sûr
nous